où on apprend que et bien à riche alors
pour retirer présent quoi alors pour
récapituler en fait le roi il en est le
roi le roi il va être couronné il va
être couronné prochain Charles III du 6
mai prochain à Westminster cérémonie
énorme grandiose ça fera 70 ans que
l'Angleterre et le monde n'ont plus
connu de couronnement le dernier
couronnement c'était en 1953 pour
Elisabeth 2 alors on apprend toute une
série de détails qui nous arrive goutte
à goutte jour après jour et ben dans les
derniers détails qui viennent de nous
arriver un peu sensationnel en effet le
prince Harry donc qui est le deuxième
fils vous savez de Charles III et qui
est un peu le fils scandaleux le mouton
noir vous savez de la série puisqu'il
vient de sortir ce fameux livre qui
s'est vendu à des millions d'exemplaires
sur lequel il balance sur l'ensemble de
sa famille et bien contre toute attente
il serait présent au couronnement le 6
mai prochain alors que bah les
spécialistes d'ailleurs disaient en
grande partie que voilà on avait du mal
à imaginer un rabibochage d'accord alors
c'est fatiguant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et donc le prince Harry il veut se
réconcilier avec son père le prince
Harry alors je vous avoue Cyril qu'on
sait pas tellement si c'est ça qui veut
se réconcilier avec son père ou si c'est
son père qui veut se réconcilier avec le
prince Harry de façon à ce que plus rien
ne fuites dans la crèche et ça meuf à
venir mais apparemment elle ne tiendrait
pas mais tout ça ce sont des
supputations on n'est pas suffisamment
vraiment dans le clan je ne peux pas je
ne peux pas vous balancer avec certitude
ce que je peux vous dire en tout cas
c'est que là on sait depuis quelques
minutes seulement que des pas Paradis
sont en train de rejoindre l'aéroport
qui est le plus proche du château twins
parce que exceptionnellement le roi nous
apprend ce soir qu'il dort à Winsor
chose il ne fait jamais Charles ne
supporte pas de rami ça parce que le
couloir aérien et l'aéroport Dijon et
qui ne supporte pas cela et bien il dort
ce soir vous sortez on pense pourquoi
c'est parce que Harry voudrait le voir
dit-on et aurait demandé une entrevue et
alors pourquoi Windsor parce que eh bien
c'est moi fréquenté que l'autre donc il
serait plus dans l'anonymat le fait de
venir voir son père ce soir au château
Tunis voilà donc un peu ah concilia
bulle qui serait en train d'être
organisé là dans les ordres qui vont
fumer
c'est pas de la petite j'ai l'impression
d'être dans X-Files
maintenant je veux juste savoir du coup
il dort où
[Musique]
donc il est originaire
aux États-Unis avec sa femme voilà
il cultive des légumes je crois dans
leur jardin et tout ça ils sont très
escargot
et donc du coup il dort où lui
donc on pense que ce soir le roi va
dormir au château de Twin sort que c'est
passionnant et par contre Harry lui va
dormir à chaque mort cottage il y a un
petit un petit pavillon qu'il possède
dans ce qu'on appelle Winsor village qui
est le voilà le domaine
la rencontre elle aurait lieu dans les
minutes qui vont suivre
on pense que chaque arrive avec des
exigences très précises avec son père
avec son père il lui va dormir un fuck
mort à chaque mort cottage je veux
savoir un petit un petit une petite
bicoque un petit pavillon dont ils ont
hérité d'Elisabeth 2
pardon ça commence ça veut dire quoi en
français chaque marque
les grenouilles
vous avez l'esprit mal tourné
d'autres choses d'autres choses une
toute petite parenthèse simplement pour
dire donc c'est vous l'avez compris le 6
mai prochain c'est le weekend de tout
entier qui va être consacré au
couronnement messe de couronnement le
samedi
en concert de couronnement le dimanche
grande journée caritative le lundi et on
attend déjà on espère que Elisabeth II
ils espèrent les médias faire 4
milliards de téléspectateurs l'ombre va
donc se transformer en énorme studio de
télévision mais du coup il dort
combien de temps cette rencontre ciao
oui petite info pardon de la prendre
mais je vais souvent à Londres
que pardon que Mégane ne viendra pas
réconciliation il faut qu'elle soit pas
là c'était un ordre du père elle reste
là où elle est elle a foutu la merde
elle reste aux États-Unis sans Burger et
les deux vont se parler tranquillement
entre eux et vous allez vous mettre tous
les peuples ados vous les Américains les
Mexicains mais enfin Mathieu mais
qu'est-ce que tu sais pas que dans le
fond il arrive pas comme exigence que
Mégane soit là
je suis à Londres juste pour te le dire
je suis à Liège
et moi je te dis que les infos que tu
donnes la Matthieu et bien elle ne pense
pas être recoupée à l'heure actuelle ce
n'est pas possible que si tu es sûr de
toi
devant Elodie me fait remarquer on
dirait qu'il y a un pigeon au-dessus
d'elle
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant mais c'est un truc de
fouet
c'est très drôle oui c'était la fameuse
donnée à Oprah d'accord ils ont pensé
quoi la famille royale des dernières
révélations d'Harry et Mégane à nouveau
mais en tout cas tu sais un truc
d'informations
rien du tout alors qu'on pensait
justement qu'ils allaient le faire
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont fait ce que la
famille royale fait de mieux on sauve
les apparences on fait comme s'il n'y
avait rien et là on le voit très
subtilement Charles il essaye de
rabibocher le clan de façon à ce que la
famille au maximum soit complète sous
les voûtes de risque
imbécile en fait ce que dit la presse
anglaise c'est que ah il y a des
exigences de folie
il veut garder tous ces titres donc il
veut du pognon et ils ont dit les que
Mégane reste parce que c'est
l'anniversaire de leur fils
ils vont trouver cette alibi
les gars ne va pas venir ah non parce
que elle va attends parce que une
question importante non alors pour de
vrai
[Rires]
question est-ce que c'est sincère ou
est-ce que c'est juste de l'image est-ce
que ça sert la famille royale pour le
parce que ça sert
il se réveille non non c'est de l'image
c'est de l'image c'est de l'image on est
dans les 8 soeurs on est dans la
première famille sur terre après Dieu un
seul compte les apparences leur job
c'est de représenter c'est d'incarné
donc là ce que Charles III est en train
de de d'essayer de tenter de faire c'est
de sauver les apparences pour cette
journée du 6 mais qui écrit l'histoire
le couronnement d'un roi d'Angleterre
c'est de l'histoire qui s'écrit et là il
paraît tout à l'heure donc le
couronnement c'est Charles III qui va le
faire et il sera mené par l'archevêque
de
4h
de l'église en Angleterre je disais la
dernière fois que il parle un français
qui est absolument parfait il a la
propriétaire d'une grande maison en
c'est lui entre autres qui arrivait
Mégane absolument que l'on voit là et le
courant ça va durer 3 jours alors ça va
durer 3 jours de festivités la cérémonie
une heure et demie alors que celle
d'Elisabeth a fait duré 3h et 2200
invités et on sait déjà que Albert et
Charlène de Monaco on sent parmi les
premiers à nous dire qu'ils assisteront
le président de leur présence on sait
pas si le palais va inviter les
présidents on pense que l'ensemble des
monarchies vont être représentées
l'ensemble des 56 pays que composent le
commonweight maintenant 54 56 pays le
code ent
[Applaudissements]
c'est Bertrand qui a raison bravo
Bertrand c'est 56 mais non non c'est pas
tellement que j'ai raison c'est que
Mathieu voilà ne sait pas grand chose
donc là ça va strabicher il va y aller
il va demander de l'oseille pour y aller
ou pas sur Harry Cyril voilà on va
encore dire que je ne sais rien mais
attendons quand même que ce concilia a
vu au milieu de façon à voir si ils vont
se rabicher comme en effet le 18
pourquoi tous les deux avec des
exigences énormes il va maintenant
falloir trouver un terrain d'entendre
pourquoi tu vas être possible tu étais
venu en fait pour je suis venu pourquoi
parce que tu m'as demandé de venir
monsieur mon chéri j'adore je te vois
moi j'adore quand je te vois puis toi tu
dis toujours de bonnes infos voilà oui
Gilles non mais en fait là Bertrand
excusez-moi mais vous déraillez
aujourd'hui
parce que là
avec quatre lignes
en Angleterre c'est que l'archevêque
Canterbury a trouvé le compromis idéal
et donc sous son égide maintenant c'est
effectivement sûr que arrive à venir
sans Mégane qu'il aura une place au
premier rang comme il veut et c'est le
roi qui a cédé donc c'est Harry qui a
supplanté l'autorité du roi c'est ça qui
est fou est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ces infos mais si vous osez vous
mouiller à ce point là
tu répètes des conneries de magazines
comme France dimanche pas du tout quand
même au moins il a des infos lui il
vient pas
vous lisez pas la presse anglaise c'est
étonnant dimanche
ce que l'on peut reprendre dans ce que
Gilles dit en effet c'est que il
semblerait que le monsieur que l'on a vu
là tout à l'heure et Justin Welby
l'arche avec des conneries et vraiment
jouer en effet un rôle important et que
Charles train ne pouvait pas il aurait
tenté de réconcilier lui-même un peu
[Musique]
aussi toute trouvée et par ailleurs elle
sera contente parce qu'on commentera
énormément son absence pas commenter
énormément son absence mais ce serait
bien à pire pour Harry moi je trouve
d’être absent là parce que lui il est ce
qu'on appelle un prince de sang il est
né prince de son père et ce sera un peu
je trouve un peu comme gifler l'histoire
le fait de ne pas que c'est le père
c'est le fils du roi
Christ est le fils du nouveau absolument
de l'argent ou des avantages en nature
notamment plus de sécurité est-ce que la
famille royale la plus de sécurité pour
lui ah est-ce que la famille royale elle
pourrait payer vraiment est-ce qu'elle
pourrait s'abaisser à ça un vrai point
qui va être négocié apparemment et pour
lequel Harry Megane sont demandeurs
depuis très longtemps c'est qu'ils ont
perdu la sécurité de Scotland Yard
lorsqu'ils sont sur le territoire
anglais puisqu'ils n'ont plus de
prédicat d'Altesse royale ils doivent
donc assurer eux-mêmes leur sécurité et
ça leur coûte énormément d'argent et en
effet un des points de cette
réconciliation serait en effet de tenter
lorsqu'ils sont du moins sur le
territoire désormais britannique tu as à
nouveau puisqu'il est prince quand même
du Royaume-Uni il garde il puisse garder
cette protection d'accord j'ai entendu
parler de première tension entre Harry
et Meghan est-ce qu'il y a de l'eau dans
le gaz ou pas est-ce que c'est
la vérité très honnêtement
Daniel a des vrais Imposs non non mais
il y a eu des tensions parce que voilà
c'est la famille
moi je je crois qu'ils vont divorcer
très vite donc je reste sur ma ligne et
c'est la première fois que je vois dans
des presque sérieuse je l'espère oui
je le sens vous savez l'expérience
enregistrons bien cette émission vous
verrez que derrière
et Élisabeth II à l'époque parce que la
retiré le fameux prédicat d'Altesse
royale
elle ne l'a pas supprimé il n'est plus
il n'est plus et ça il n'est plus son
Altesse Royale on ne peut plus l'appeler
Harry réalité
sur décision du roi Charles il pourrait
très bien réintégrer ces fonctions et à
nouveau prévenir au balcon saluer la
foule comme si de rien n'était pas ça
vous verrez dans deux trois ans
Elisabeth II et ses équipes surtout bah
déjà elle savait peut-être une petite
idée derrière la tête de se dire la
seule mariage là une durée il est
content d'être éternel Charles est-ce
qu'on est content d'être roi Cyril c'est
relou des trois ou pas on se pose pas la
question c'est l'histoire qui a voulu
qu'un jour on doit faire quoi on fait
quoi quand on est roi baron
donc il va devoir la sortir tous les
jours le matin le sortir d'accord vous
avez je suis convaincre gratuite la
photo
tu aimes bien Camilla toi j'adore
Camille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
combien de temps qu'elle est Charles
c'est un beau personnage dans le sens où
aimer toute sa vie en œuvre qui a eu des
enfants et elle nous a montré quand même
Camila que quand on est amoureux c'est
qu'on continue à y croire et bah les
contes de fées ça existe un peu en fait
elle est parvenue non mais c'est fou et
donc il s'est marié avec elle
absolument en 2005 avril 2005 c'est fou
ça et les enfants et juste je peux te
poser une question les enfants lui en
veulent pas camélia parce qu'il savait
que c'était quand même la maîtresse de
son de son de leur daron
qui fait grave sa mère c'est bien normal
et donc il devait il doit être vénère
après la meuf avec son père et vous
savez
un moment donné ils ont presque supplié
Charles de ne pas épouser Camila oui ils
lui ont dit on sait que tu l'aimes
d'accord mais est-ce que ça doit
forcément passer par là
donc là le truc voilà il y a il y a rien
ils sont comment Harry et Camille Harry
et Camille
Camilla ça ne me voilà les tensions
seraient énormes en revanche avec
William qui est l'autre fils celui qui a
un jour sera roi qui était
dans les rouges
c'est que il était amoureux d'elle bien
avant qui arrive Diana et que elle a
refusé le mariage donc d'être princesse
très beau comme elle a refusé le pote
c'est pour ça qu'il a oui c'est pour ça
qu'il a épousé Diana et quand il a
divorcé de Diana il l'a épousé donc elle
a refusé au départ de devenir princesse
c'est la seule qui a été véritablement
amoureuse de son amoureux finalement
parce que toutes les autres Mégane il a
laissé elles étaient faites pour être
prêt elle était mariée
mais pas les équipes de Buckingham
Palace les équipes et elles ont combien
donc le mariage d'accord
c'est pas possible donc Camilla c'est
impossible qu'elle fasse quelque chose
quand même elle est reine là maintenant
ils sont divorcés ils continuent à se
voir d'ailleurs je pense et on rappelle
jamais Tom et Laura
maintenant dès ta première mariage donc
ils ne font pas partie de la famille
royale dans le fond ils seront
probablement ils sont rebelles c'est pas
probablement ils seront meilleurs
parce que leur mère est couronné
absolument incroyable c'est incroyable
elle est les reines et l'autre ils sont
prince donc qui le père à la William là
William il est désormais
de ce titre il est un peu difficile à
porter la couleur
et donc elle arrive les princes de rien
et Harry les non il est prince de rien
parce qu'il est du cuit il est sexy
frère maintenant que je suis je m'en
fous quoi il est con il est baron
ketchup
qu'il quittait ses fonctions de la
famille royale il n'a plus de il n'a
plus d'allocation qui sont versées par
le palais
que son allocation de militaires puisque
on rappelle que il a servi en
Afghanistan